this doesn't have any tans in it so it
doesn't know it turns it but this does
so there are no tans so I'm gonna put
detective right I also notice I also
notice for instance I have see the terms
here in my fraction right do you notice
there's a cubed term and a squared term
and one tan theta and are close to 10 do
you notice that and you notice the
numbers that I have here how many how
many 10 cubes
do I have live negative 1/5 one of these
how many 10 squares do I have I know
you're three of them that's kind of
sauce right ok let's let's unpack this
right I'm going to let X equal ten theta
that's my first line ok let X equal 10
theta and by the way this is a classic
example of what does get done in
extension tree because now you have this
this whole world of more challenging
identities now over to you okay so I'm
gonna just do my straight substitution
this is 10 cubed + 3 10 squared minus 3
10 okay now how can I get how can I drop
this into something like this that I can
take advantage of so I want to give me a
suggestion I do need to divide by
something right I kinda want to divide
by this don't you see that where is that
yeah well there's my 1 and there's my 3
x squared so I'm gonna move them on the
other side yep
so I'm going to add 1 to both sides and
I'm going to subtract 3 10 squared theta
from both sides okay now I can divide
right but you don't watch out you know
as usual when dividing dividing remove
solutions from an equation right just
like if I gave you this which has three
solutions if I divide through by X in
this case right I get a solution it's a
it's an actual solution but I've lost
the solution right what am i lost
I've lost x equals zero right when I did
that however in fact in this case you
know what X can equal zero so that's why
when you state this when you remove it
from the unpossible solutions you could
find algebraically you've got to go back
and test it in exactly the same way that
when you do T results to yourselves take
a solution out of the plane right
they take PI pi PI onto its refined to
et cetera okay which therefore ms-office
earth in your pi equals pi because it's
you know half angle results on the same
thing is happening here though right
when I divide by one minus three x
squared equals equals one one I'm taking
solutions out of play right what
solutions am i taking out of play good
so what I've said at this point here is
one minus three tan squared theta can't
equal to zero right so I'm not going to
do it now for the sake of time but you
would you'd have to go and check this is
ten theta equals plus or minus 103 right
which is PI over 6 6 6 6 plus or minus
pound six ok so you check those okay but
I just under store your attention to it
okay yeah
that's why she Michael traits and I
wouldn't like know immediately that I
was doing this okay yeah sure that's a
great question
when dealing with angles okay and it's a
little bit unfortunate this is the way
it's been the whole of like you're 11
and 12 mathematics has really been
focused on and it will continue to focus
even more on calculus like why are we
doing algebra and functions could you
need to understand calculus why are we
doing st. Street extensions because you
need them when you're doing the calculus
of trig functions right you can't you
can't deal with in any other way um
therefore degrees kind of go away
degrees are useful because there were
they're easy in whole numbers when
you've got like a rectangle and that
kind of thing but when you're doing like
proper maths with them you have to do it
in radians okay however you know if you
if you wanted to stay sixty or thirty
degrees right you just say thirty
degrees but that is the same as pi on
six you would get not down if you had to
do some calculus in here which at the
moment we're not right because calculus
and I'm gonna get to the reasons why
when we introduce hi this has to be done
in radians it's a bit unusual to
understand what difference is the units
make kind of does make a difference for
you for remember these are units and I
prove to you I showed you why by
definition these are not in not actually
units so we're not comparing some units
it's like I like metric versus I like
Imperial no no no no no we're comparing
units and and mathematics without use
ratios exactly so that's why it works so
if there were calculus involved yes you
would if the original question
gave it in terms of like it gave to a
domain restrictions in terms of radians
you would be expected to use radians the
easy answer is always to use radians
unless they tell you otherwise okay now
I'm almost a I'm not gonna finish
solving this two for you just because of
time but I'm gonna map out
for you this is useful almost right it's
not the tripling of one person come on
it's masquerading I need to take a
factor negative one out so in order to
get this numerator facing the right
direction and have that 3/10 either at
the front I'm gonna say 3 tan-theta -
and cute and then this guy but being
that I took the factor of negative 1 out
there it's got to go somewhere
I don't want to go in the denominator
because that's the right way well now
what I've got is that this is 10 3 theta
okay like sir like I just went and
proved that right yeah yeah do that so
what I have done now is I transformed a
polynomial question into a quick trick
question actually know what this is not
that hard to do
um remember when we were doing the
finding the nth roots the the roots of
the complex are not right what we what
we eventually got up to is a point like
this we'd say caused by de maras there
you don't like cost three feet over here
something like that and then you'd say I
have an angle there
right do you remember this so they don't
say well the most obvious solution to
this is when these two things are
identical that's the most obvious
solution 50 feet up can be pilot sees
itself but it's not the only solution
cosine is periodic every how many
radians every two radians so I cannot I
can add any even multiple of pi write
that plus 2pi that force four PI plus
six five-year or good and subtraction as
well right now when I look at this how
can I take advantage of this knowledge
here I already have ten something equals
ten something else the chat that do what
is this ten off - very good now
admittedly if you didn't see that right
away that's that's okay your calculator
can tell you I'll do 10 inverse of
negative one and no hanju negative
powerful brain thankfully so the most
obvious are thoughts and this is three
thing dot equals minus PI over four
when those two answers are the same okay
but we know there are loads more
solution
more solutions unlike cosine mode I had
to keep high because the period of
cosine is what again it's 2pi every to
find every piece right but ten is not
periodic every 2 pi it's periodic every
PI radians so in fact I don't add two K
pi I add K PI again for integer values
okay okay I guess at this point I would
divide through 12 okay and now we're
literally at the same point we were on
here
do you remember from here to find the UM
you know say the cube roots of whatever
complex numbers I was dealing with I
would then I would just go through that
values of K right I'm gonna go through
until I get all of the solutions that
I'm expecting okay yes okay great
question right so let's just find one
solution for this okay you can find the
rest of them you can even crunch through
okay
what's an obvious solution what's the
first solution you would like of is
minus 512 thank you okay so example
right I'm gonna call it theta 1 theta 1
or K 2 0 when K equals 0 I'm gonna get
in the first feed which is minus plant
well okay now I need to reduced all the
versus theta myself right there you see
that so if - pylon 12 is a solution for
theta right then 10 pylon 12 is a
solution for X does that make sense so
what I've done is it's just like when
you do substitution it's like oh great
I introduced you equals two to the X or
something like that but I know what
solution to you are what solutions in X
so I climb back up the ladder and I say
if that's a solution for theta I say
therefore correspondingly the first
solution for X is tan of 5 and 12 which
I have no idea what its actual value is
but you go ahead and find it oh sorry
we will of course get some positive
solutions I mean the next one my spine
12 plus PI on 3 is gonna be like - sorry
it's getting 3 yeah you'll be 3 PI and
12 weight which is PI over 4 so I owe
you my next solution and in my next
solution and you can evaluate this like
10 power 4 is just 1 right
does it does it work one plus three
minus three minus one Bend reconsider
right and when you get to 10 planets
well but this is some can someone give
me what is it like I assume it's a
certain of some kind right yeah it's
something weird only concern okay now
when you take that you can you can pop
it in here literally assign it to a
variable on your calculator like call it
8 and then do a cube plus 3 a squared
minus 3 a minus 1 it's a weird no but
you'd never get by like Larry factorize
that but the trigonometry tells you the
solution okay so it's quite it's quite
profound bringing together these strains
to solve an otherwise insoluble question
or a nice very challenging using the
methods that you had before okay so how
do you remember I did I rubbed it off so
from here just like the tea results
right so this is me dealing with the
restriction that I added by dividing
right I had it in so I better take care
of it right um the solutions that I'm
ignoring are tan theta equals plus or
minus 103 which I think we were saying
is plus or minus response aches
okay so then I would say well okay these
are potential solutions are missing a
potential solution of vision so what I
will test is x equals 10 and of that
right looking for example I'll go to 10
minus 6
okay so I would I would in fact I don't
even really need to do this I can just
go straight to x equals tan theta what I
was going to want to root 3/1 it's gonna
be minus 1 over 3 and then I I put them
in write more instance okay let's do one
every three the positive one you can't
come up 103 cute is one
three isn't it 103 three lots of 103
squared is third right - three of 103 -
one what is this thing
okay let's see um three that's um that's
that's one and that disappears over
there I've got one on three root three
take away three on group - I don't care
what that is it's not it's not zero so
it's not a solution
so I'm fine I've eliminated I that out
of the running but it wasn't a solution
anyway so great you know just like when
you test them on the equal pi does work
does or not it's not on fire